foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
do not be alarmed
always get somebody with this when I hop
on earlier
oh boy it's gonna be a spicy one tonight
chat I can already tell
it is going to be a spicy one indeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right
all right all right all right people of
the internet
hello and welcome ladies and gentlemen
to Retro rack and Tour live
I'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell I gotta remember to
start doing that every time to start the
live stream
because we we don't say it as much on
the the actual videos anymore
so we gotta remember to say it here but
how's everybody doing tonight welcome
welcome
in welcome in
we've got I don't know one or two things
one or two things on the agenda to
discuss tonight
oh boy one or two things
we could start out with some fun things
first or wait did we talk about that
we talked about that last I think we
talked about it last week that
pretty much Alicia and I and the rest of
the stream oh and the power of Thor's
hammer
made the jumping announcement happen
uh or at least we had a small hand in it
I'll just say we at least had a hand in
it I won't take I won't hear anything
otherwise yo check it out we actually
got the uh
those are popping up correctly now which
let's see here who do we got
Dr Robo panned a 39 minutes ago I don't
know if Dr robot Panda maybe couldn't
make it to the live but they renewed
their membership a little bit before we
started uh then we had Elwyn gifting
five tier one memberships to start us
off and let's see Neil Harrison got one
Neil I feel like Neil Harrison
Neil always hanging out getting one of
those gifteds congrats Neil Psalm
Brockie brick plays and Jenny all
getting gifted subs from L1 elwin thank
you so much for your support of the
channel of the stream and congrats to
those of you who just got a gift to
membership
if you're new to the whole YouTube live
stream anything what does a membership
do you may ask well all those little fun
emoji that you see people using that are
Wizarding World and or retro raconteur
related uh you have access to those now
anywhere on the channel so you can use
those in comments on my videos and of
course you can use them here in the live
stream as well also get discounted merch
uh priority reply comments there's a
whole whole list of things you can check
out but mainly memberships are just a
monetary way for you to help out support
streamers support content creators a
little bit and then I I try and make it
worth your while try and make give
something back in return so Ellen thank
you so much for your support and then um
right after Elwyn Let's see we had
Ravenclaw Tyrell gifting five more
memberships so Ravenclaw Tyrell thank
you for the five gifteds looks like
Jacob Peterson Nathan senate or sanat
and I'm sure if I'm pronouncing that
correctly Nathan I remember seeing your
name though Marcus DJ Darth starkilla
and Apex rager all just got a gift of
membership from Ravenclaw Terrell Ravel
call Tyrell thank you so much and
congrats to those of you who just got
one of the gifteds
and if you stick around long enough here
you got a pretty good chance of getting
one guys because we have a very generous
Community who is almost constantly
gifting because let's see right after
that one we had five more tier one Subs
come in from lowercase Logan lower case
Logan good to see you again my friend by
the way guys if you didn't notice look I
changed up the position of the
microphone a little bit it used to be
like
welcome morning down but now I moved it
here and I can actually see the screen
much better now don't one of those
simple things you know don't know why I
didn't think of it before but now I
thought of it and it's working it's
working well
all right so lowercase Logan with those
gifted uh memberships right there it
looks like show c-h-o-s-u-c
uh Janae Jenna Lee Jenna Lee I bet Jenna
Lee Turner Jerry and Olimar 92 I
remember that name Olimar welcome back
congrats on the gifted membership and
then Kathy as well with the gifted
membership from lowercase Logan so Logan
thank you for the support it's just been
like nearly headless Nick just been I
did you guys notice I turned him down a
little bit I did turn him down just a
smidge oh man we get so many gifted
memberships community so generous like
John Cleese here trying to steal my
thunder all the time
so I gotta we gotta turn him down just a
bit so nearly headless Nick I didn't
want to take him away but he's a little
bit lower now a little bit lower than he
was before lowercase Logan thank you so
much and then right on the heels of
lowercase Logan we had Noob gifting out
five tier one memberships Noob yet
another regular
membership here of house rack and tour
guys Dominic Scott Aaron Brewer The Ore
division Chris W and Mark termite guys
all of you all these names have just
been shouting out welcome you are now
officially a member of House raconteur
thank you so much for being here uh oh
also Nico's gonna get me one one of the
benefits I always forget to to talk
about is the uh the Discord role the
special Discord role so I think we went
with prefect for the Discord role so
exclamation point Discord there in the
chat if you're not a member of the
Discord yet hop on over there join oh it
was let's get a little spicy today just
as I knew the stream would be spicy
tonight getting a little spicy over
there in the Discord or division good to
see you here again hanging out as well
or division got one of those gifteds all
right and then let's see I think we are
fully caught up on all the memberships
so guys welcome in welcome in if you
haven't voted in the poll question yet
make sure you vote in this because this
is going to play oh my gosh it's the
switch really at one percent
holy cow one person uh poll question
guys
because I want to see how many people
this announcement today is affecting
I had a feeling it wouldn't be the
majority but I feel like there is a fair
number of people that today's uh news
which you're going to get to is
affecting so the the question which
platform do you plan to play Hogwarts
Legacy on PS5 Xbox series X also if you
have an Xbox series s it's under that
Xbox branding umbrella so you're in that
category as well and then also PC
next category last gen systems
PlayStation 4 Xbox One
if you're in that category you'll vote
for the second one and then the final
category Nintendo switch which somehow
is went down to zero I don't know how it
went down to zero but it's down at zero
now
it was just one percent a second ago so
vote in that poll we're going to talk
about that here in a bit when we discuss
the news also 215 votes in the poll
let's get those likes up guys as soon as
we hit a hundred likes here in the
Stream
we'll do a little random Harry Potter
quote trivia
little random Harry Potter quote trivia
for you guys which let's see where oh my
goodness it was at 32 and then as soon
as I clicked on the button it jumped to
57.
we'll do a little Harry Potter quote
trivia see how test your guys's
knowledge you're a wizard Harry we might
go with an easier one this week the past
couple weeks we've been going a little
bit more difficult so
Haggard what's up my friend Hagrid uh
Curtis Swanson welcome thank you for
subscribing to the channel here oh yeah
there was one thing I forgot actually I
don't know I think the camera looks good
where it's at but I have the option
if I want to
let me see here let me see if this looks
any better if we zoom in just slightly
oh yeah that does look better I think
that does look better being a little bit
closer like that but
not don't I don't have as much Headroom
so
whoa what do we have here Rossi well or
Rosie r-o-s-s-y
Super Chat thank you so much Rossi for
the Super Chat petition to make you the
next showcase co-host
right that's another big thing we got to
talk about because a gameplay showcase
has been revealed
and it's not me just like I told you
yeah I told you guys it wasn't me
um had a feeling they were going to be
doing another one not sure how many more
they're going to be doing
but what I told you guys before remains
true it remains true
no no shake it no no showcase no
showcases in my future
um
as ever as of now you know things could
always change tomorrow right but as of
now no showcases in my future
which I feel like I have to be so
careful now whenever I answer these like
as soon as it came out that Ben was the
next one I heard so many people saying
dude I totally knew Ben acted so strange
I guess somebody brought it up in I
don't know on his stream or
and apparently some people felt like he
gave it away but like at this point it's
hard
I mean a lot of people thought James uh
James's significant other Sue
James uh expect to go if you guys aren't
familiar he he mentioned I think he was
in his Discord he mentioned like Sue's
out of town or something for a for a
work trip so in James's Community work
trip has very quickly become code for oh
you must be doing a gameplay showcase
but uh guys I see all the love I do I
see a lot of you on uh on Twitter and
in the Reddit and on the Discord as well
I see your support and it means a lot
thank you very much
um yeah yeah it means a lot I'm very
happy for Ben I know Ben will do a great
job just as James did a great job but um
I see I see your comments and it really
does mean a lot that you all uh that you
all feel I would be I would be a good
choice so thank you for the Super Chat
and then we had lowercase Logan uh
bouncing right back with another Super
Chat Dylan started off the gifts with
five wait what did I completely Miss
Dylan
oh my goodness you guys got so many in
there
oh no I think the uh
for some reason dude I do remember
seeing Dylan's in my in my chat window
but you're completely right it did not
show up in my in my alerts here
[Music]
yeah Dylan so sorry my friend Dylan also
a channel member a member of House
Dragon tour long time supporter uh and a
moderator here so
Dylan so sorry I missed that and I can't
I can't even see who got the gifteds
can't see who got the gifted membership
so
weird usually I can see it here and I
can cause it to trigger again
but yeah they're not showing up oh well
thank you very much Dylan appreciate it
and lowercase Logan thank you for the
clarification and making sure that I
didn't uh didn't miss those and then
right after lowercase Logan we had
reptile frenzy LLC with a ten dollar
Super Chat reptile thank you so much for
the Super Chat and uh the the comment
there says thank you for all that you do
brother reptile thank you so much for
the support thank you guys all for the
support man what a way to start the
stream I I had a feeling it was going to
be a very uh busy stream in terms of
discussion didn't necessarily anticipate
so much love right here in the beginning
but thank you guys so much
for all the love and then we had Dr
sherbet in there as well okay yeah I
don't know if you guys are coming in too
fast with the alerts or what but Dr
sherbet's
see that one didn't show up there either
wow okay guys yeah if I miss your alert
my fault the the alerts are kind of
acting wonky right now but Dr sherbet
can't believe I've been here for two
months thank you and everyone here for
making me feel so welcomed and part of a
great Phantom Dr sherbet thank you so
much for being here I'll never forget Dr
sherbet because the first time I saw
them in chat we had to have a
conversation about sherbet and the
pronunciation of it
I don't know if it was a southern thing
or what we talked about this but my
family growing up always pronounced it
sherbert
and one day I was you know I was old
enough to look and and actually see the
letters I was like wait what there's no
extra R in there is it sherbet
so yeah we looked it up it's sherbet
it's sherbet yeah so I don't know I
don't know where that thing came from
but Dr sherbet thank you for being here
thank you for the support and then we
also had let's see another one
uh Noob jumping in there with another
Super Chat Noob with a RAR Noob starting
the rars again this week Noob thank you
so much for the Super Chat once again
and let's let's shout out everybody here
hanging out in the Stream tonight
because
man there's a lot of you in here a lot
of you in here so we always try and do
this at the beginning very quickly uh
and then we'll jump into the news of
which there is a lot
of which there is a lot all right so we
got Alicia here in the house tonight
Alicia is a member of House wreck and
tour we got alte Salen Andrew awful
awful Artful bee Barbie brick plays and
then uh
c-h-o-s-u-c both of those back to back
right there members of house wrecking
tour Clint is here Dr sherbet Dominic
Draco Draven Dustin elwin from Dr
sherbet on down right there all those
members of house rack into her expired
seaweed what a great name by the way
Jack the gamer Jack Attack welcome uh
Jenny is here John Dingus back again
Jordan Crawford JP raven fire all
members Val sarakan tour right there
Kylie YT Lauren D is here uh little
picket lowercase Logan those are members
of house Dragon tour we got Luna Comics
Matt Lewis I'm still dying to know if
that's the Matt Lewis like Matt Lewis
from the Harry Potter series you guys
know
that'd be how awesome would that be
they're just Matt Lewis just lurking in
the streams and he gets gifted a
membership oh even if you're not the
Matt Lewis Matt you're a valued member
here welcome I'm happy to have you here
Matt Matt Lewis Moon Lily and Noob all
three of those members of house Dragon
tour uh Nathan Nicholas then we got Nico
pineapple Sam pineapple Sam member of
House wrecking tour along with Nico I
don't know if I've seen pineapple Sam's
name before but welcome Ravenclaw Tyrell
another member of House Dragon tour uh
Rossi who just had that Super Chat a
couple moments ago Ryan oh member of
House wrecking tour there shadow in 925
uh Taylin or I think it's they might be
Talon Talon price member of House record
tour
tgd J F Beady welcome thank you for
being here Todd uh Tracy sticks or
Stacks not sure thank you for being here
true Jedi love the Sith and then Ultra
Blue Jr is here as well uh vpnon Japan
and member of House Dragon tour welcome
and then William bradseph
there is no that is not all the people
here right now so but that is all the
ones showing in the participants list so
if I missed you guys my apologies
my apologies but I'm gonna catch up on
uh open up the chat now and we will jump
in there if anything happened Dylan
apparently I missed your your gifted so
my fault my friend my fault that I
missed them we corrected it though we
made it right Dylan thank you for all
the gifteds thank you very much for the
gift it's oh and we need to check on
hold on let's see before I switch to the
next scene here we might already have we
were closing in on 100 likes we might
already be there and chat you probably
already told me if we did hit it we did
we crossed it all right time for a
little Harry Potter quote quiz
little Harry Potter quote quiz so the
rules here guys uh first you name the
character and then you get bonus points
in our imaginary list of points
here behind me
what do you win you win gratitude my
gratitude and recognition here in the
chat
all right so again uh character first
and then if you can name the book so we
try to stick to Harry Potter book quotes
and not movie quotes
all right let's go with this book right
here
oh dude that one that one would be super
difficult right there like just some
obscure character
foreign
let's see here
like there are some that are just
obvious right away this isn't the one
but because of the way because of the
way they're written I am what I am and
I'm not ashamed never be ashamed my old
dad used to say there's some who will
hold it against you but they're not
worth bothering with
it's just certain little mannerisms in
the speech you can always notice exactly
who it is
oh okay this is a fun one this is a fun
one
all right all right all right I like
this one right here
okay so here's the quote again named
character and then name the book If you
know which which book it's from
all right so here's the quote
anyone can speak troll
all you have to do is point and grunt
don't look it up guys that ruins the fun
don't look it up
here's the quote again anyone can speak
troll
all you have to do is point and grunt
Dominic I think I need a cooler screen
name oh what's wrong with Dominic
Dominic's all good
PS1 Hagrid
yeah yeah you guys are right about the
Hagrid on the other one though for sure
right that one's always very obvious
good old rubius Hagrid
all right so now on the on the the real
quote we got Ron we got Fred Goblet of
Fire from Alicia Ron first or second
book Ron Ron and book three Professor
Quirrell philosopher stone uh Shadow and
I think this is Ron quote Haggard book
one maybe Clint was talking about the
other one Ron no idea just feel like he
would say that Ron book four Ron
philosopher stone Ron book five Ron Ron
Deathly Hallows Ron sorcerer Stone Ron
sorcerer Stone Ron
Fred Goblet of Fire Dylan with the all
caps maybe he's very Dylan could be very
convinced here Draco Chamber of Secrets
Fred Weasley Goblet of Fire isn't that
Fred Weasley Goblet of Fire Moon Lily
says housekeeper one leaky caught now
see that would be difficult I'll tell
you guys the one I was thinking of doing
that would have been super difficult
Trevor said Deathly Hallows Ron Weasley
needs hashtag or Ron Weasley needs love
too right
Fred uh g-o-g-o-b I think they could be
g-o-f Goblet of Fire
oh shadowing you got it
retro book three uh no that one's
incorrect definitely a Weasley who said
that definitely a Fred quote from Goblet
of Fire Moon Lily says more Hagrid uh
Moon Lily little picket with the
laughter there all right so correct
answer
there were a lot of people thinking
wrong you guys were totally right that
it was a Weasley though uh but those who
were that those who were convinced that
it was Fred Weasley were correct
Fred Weasley from Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire and again the quote if
you guys missed it if you're just
jumping in it was anyone can speak troll
all you have to do is point and grunt
all right always love doing that so the
other one the one I was like this would
be so ridiculously hard
um
well where'd it go where'd it go
it was right
that's the spirit dear
that's probably been said more than once
in the series
that's the spirit dear
I'll see if anybody knows that it was
Trevor no it wasn't Trevor
definitely not Trevor
R.I.P Fred indeed
oh yeah rip the one percent playing on
switch okay it is back up to one now 335
votes now if you guys haven't voted in
the poll and you're just jumping into
the stream make sure you vote in the
poll trying to figure out how much uh
today's news impacts those of you
watching the stream uh which platform do
you plan to play Hogwarts Legacy on if
you're on current gen or PC so Xbox
series s or X or PC or PS5 you vote in
that first category uh if you're going
to be playing on PS4 or Xbox One you
vote in the second and then if your
Nintendo switch you vote in the last
category there
Crookshanks McGonagall deathly House
part two some ghost because spirit
Spirit no it was um this one was from
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
I don't even remember this one so it
starts off the quote I'm not going to be
murdered Harry's Harry Harry said out
loud that's the spirit deer said his
mirror sleepily
when like the mirror talking back was
his reflection talking back to him
I do not remember that at all
I'm not gonna be murdered Harry said out
loud that's the spirit dear said his
mirror sleepily
[Music]
book three portrait in the Leaky
cauldron Brittany coming through there
nicely done
isn't that the quote Yeah the mirror wow
I'm surprised anybody
I did not remember that at all yeah so I
guess the mirror in uh
when he's staying at the end right at
the league cauldron
good call Brittany
I think Brittany was the first one I saw
who got it in the chat
Mrs fake book five I like that guest
though Neil I like that guess
all right guys that's it for the quotes
let's go ahead and change scenes and
move over to the Hogwarts Legacy news
[Music]
again of which there has been a lot
there has been a lot
where do we even start all right all
right all right I'm just gonna I'm not
gonna put up a poll for this I'm just
gonna go by chat reactions do we start
with good news chat or do we start with
the bad news just say good or bad you
want good news first or bad news I mean
you guys already know all the stuff
anyway probably but in terms of our
discussion in terms of talking about it
which one you want first which one do
you want first you want the good or you
want the bad
all right let's see we got no caps with
the good we got bad bad bad good bad bad
bad first yeah I feel like everybody
always you always want to get the bad
out of the way right bad bad
so we can end on a good note bad just
jump into the bed rip off the Band-Aid
that's me yeah I feel like almost
everybody always take when you get that
choice it's like almost always the bad
news first is what people choose
my honest opinion it's all good news
Draco says
Noob with another Super Chat jumping in
there Noob thank you so much for the
Super Chat yet again and we do have a
fully
um completely filled can tonight of our
black cherry Waterloo
black cherry Waterloo Noob thanks so
much for the Super Chat
all right
you guys want the bat first okay so here
we go
here we go so today
December 13th let's check the date
uh we got the news right here that
Hogwarts Legacy has been officially
delayed they didn't use the word delay
but it is indeed a delay four
the PlayStation 4 and Xbox One versions
so here's the full post from them
Hogwarts Legacy will launch on April 4th
so it's not a huge delay
2023 for PlayStation 4 and Xbox One and
on July 25th for Nintendo switch so
switch I don't know maybe that's good
bad indifferent depending on
we didn't have a switch date at all so I
guess it's good that we do we do know
the date now and it is going to be you
know still in the first uh not quite the
first half of the year
uh the team is looking forward to
bringing you the game and we want to
deliver the best possible game
experience across all platforms so
clearly what they're doing here they're
prioritizing the current gen as they
should along with a PC
now
here's where it gets murky
this next quote here we understand there
could be questions around the impacts of
this delay for PS4 and Xbox One for more
information please visit the FAQ we're
going to jump into that here then the
last tweet Hogwarts Legacy will launch
on PlayStation 5 Xbox series X and S and
PC on February 10th so they're sticking
to that one with the 72 hour early
access beginning on February 7th 2023
and this early access portion is where
we get into the
kind of murky territory
so
if you guys remember actually I'm gonna
go to the pre-order page first because
this shows it pretty well
so if you guys remember
back when pre-orders went live
one of the big selling points of this
deluxe edition right here is the 72
hours early access that means even now
here they have it listed right on the
site 72 hours early access is a benefit
of buying this deluxe edition
they made it a perk they made it a
benefit that is not like us you know
that is not us
tacking that on I mean that's that was
clearly in the materials here uh let's
see Dr Sherman but are you eating no no
eating no snacking tonight had dinner
about an hour before hopped on so I'm
good but Dr Sherbert with another Super
Chat thank you so much and then Rossi
renewing their tier one remembership
there
I don't know what just sort of Mumble
came out of my mouth but they renewed
their tier one membership Rossi thank
you so much for that
brick plays I've pre-ordered the deluxe
see okay somebody was asking me this on
Twitter and I think it's a great
question they were saying they had
pre-ordered the PS4 digital Edition
digital deluxe edition
and it's in because that version comes
with both the PS4 and the PS5 version
that was another benefit that they
talked about it's like if you if you
pre-order the uh the deluxe on PS4 or
Xbox One you get a free next-gen upgrade
so now that person has moved on they've
gotten a PS5 in in the time between when
they pre-ordered
so they were asking me will they get to
play the game early
and I haven't responded this person yet
this reminded me I need to respond I
don't know for sure my guess is no
I would think that you would need to
cancel your pre-order for the PS4
version
which
back on the Hogwarts Legacy FAQ here
um they have a note here about
yeah right here they actually link you
to as policies vary by retailer and
region so guys we have a big Community
across many different regions here I
don't want to speak out of line and say
something that's incorrect
um but if you're in that boat
you may need to go and look at
in your territory what the return policy
is because you may just want to return
it cancel that pre-order if you can and
then pre-order the current gen version
the PS if if you're someone like that
who's already you're a wizard upgraded
and bought they had the person that
asked me on Twitter had bought a PS5 now
now the negative of that is that he the
person who who wrote me will not get
basically two copies of the game
so that would that's kind of a nice perk
if you're somebody who maybe maybe
you've got kids or maybe you've got
significant other or siblings who also
want to play and you're like oh one of
them can play on the PS4 and I can play
on the PS5 we get two versions I can
install it on the PS4 I can install the
other one on the PS5
if you if you cancel the PS4 and then
you order it for the PS5 that will not
be
uh you know you would you wouldn't get
the PS5 version if you cancel or the PS4
version I'm sorry
now I don't know that for sure I don't
know that answer for sure so
it could be different maybe maybe
I don't know I don't see how it's
different though if you've pre-ordered
the PS4 version
even though it includes a free next-gen
upgrade I don't see yeah so I'm I'm
gonna stick by that until I hear
otherwise I don't see any way that you
would be able to get the game early even
if you have a PS5 now without
official officially pre-ordering the PS5
version I'm pretty sure that's correct
pretty sure that's correct
Doctor Strange don't forget on PS5 get
to download it on the 5th of February
um I I haven't heard that where's that
at Oh you mean or do you mean for like
the uh the pre-loading like how you can
preload so you won't be able to play it
until February 7th
for the 72 hours early access maybe they
were talking about the pre
Sue's gonna be sad oh no no no that they
already solved that one Sue's gonna be
playing on PS5 along with James
you don't have the money to buy it again
brick place
um
well if are you the wait are you the one
who who messaged me
are you the one who messaged me brick
plays
if you already have a PS5 make sure you
you can just I'm pretty sure you can get
refunded
make it let's just go look here now I'm
I'm in the U.S so I don't know
all right PlayStation store okay so this
is for us guys PlayStation store refunds
uh cancel and manage purchases
cancel pre-orders all right here we go
all right how long do I have to cancel
my Playstation Store pre-order
I paid for Content more than 14 day okay
this would definitely be the case for
anyone here you can cancel anytime up to
the release date if you have not started
to download the main part of the
pre-order content including
pre-pre-loading before release
Lauren it is a scam what you were
talking about wait what do you I don't
know what's what's a scam
I'm not following you on there or were
you talking to somebody in the chat
oh that zacharillus Barkley on the
PlayStation Store it sells the digital
Deluxe with both versions
I don't think you would have to
re-pre-order unless you did it through
the Hogwarts Legacy site interesting
okay
see
I'm gonna pull this up in another window
and test this
because I that has not been my
experience but I mainly order through
like just straight through the
PlayStation 5.
okay so here's the PlayStation Store
yeah they if you're doing it through the
web they've got it listed they've got it
listed separately here
so see like the little PS4 okay now
here's the one for PS5 and then there's
the PS5 standard okay where is the
click this and see if we can get to the
PS4 Deluxe this way
oh you're okay wait wait wait wait wait
I think zacharillus is totally right
here
okay hold on hold on hold on this might
be really good news for the people who
have
oh man I'm I'm like I'm trying right now
to decide how far down this Rabbit Hole
I want to go
because there's gonna be so many there's
so many different situations for this
right like depending on which retailer
you proved so it looks like if you
pre-ordered through the PlayStation
Store just like zacharillus zacharless
Barkley thank you so much for pointing
that out it looks like if you did this
one
then it it does say PS4 and PS5 digital
versions
[Music]
right there
now let's see if you go through the
Hogwarts Legacy site so okay let's say I
choose Deluxe I choose PlayStation 4 and
I'm gonna choose I don't know Walmart
oh wait that's the hard copy
we need to look at the uh
oh wait can I not switch to
hold on addition oh wait I guess you
can't you can't switch to digital here
I don't know dude I don't know
preload okay yeah you were talking about
the preload that's what I thought I
thought so uh let's see or division what
is up my friend War division thank you
so much for the Super Chat hello
everybody hope you all are doing well
what a week right or division what a
week indeed and we're just getting
started it's only what Tuesday they're a
wizard
oh man
tell you the truth guys I've been I've
been under the weather today I didn't
know if I was going to be able to stream
tonight um we're thinking my oldest
might have the flu
but he is uh we've all we all had the
the flu shot but
yeah so it's not
I've had like a headache all day and
just been super fatigued super tired and
I was taking care of him all day
yesterday
so I didn't know if I was gonna be able
to stream and then I just like I wake up
to all this news I was like oh
I gotta I gotta find time to stream or
division thanks so much for being here
and thank you for the Super Chat
uh I haven't pre-ordered yet dealy says
I'll check on my PS5 can everyone stop
saying it's time to move on to next gen
uh Shadow and other games you get the
PS4 version and then can go to the PS5
upgrade it changes your license into a
PS5 copy you don't get both games you
get a single license and you play on
either system
it's not how it works for Eldon ring
yeah because
there was this really weird thing when
elder ring first launched where
if you wanted to play it
hold on it was like if you wanted to
play it without any stuttering you could
run the PS4 version
you could you could fully download the
PS4 version on your system
and run it on the PS5 and it would
actually run better it would run very
smooth it'd run a lot smoother than it
would on the PS4 and it ran better than
the PS5 version that was like had more
graphical bells and whistles
so yeah I that would be that would be
news to me let me read that again from
Shadow and other games you get the PS4
version and then can go to the PS5 and
upgrade
it changes your license to a PS5 copy
okay so the only time I've seen that
shadowing I think I know what you're
talking about when I've seen that is if
you have a PS4 disk
so like I have a copy of ghost of
tsushima on PS4 I have a Spider-Man on
PS4
and if I put that disc in it actually
gives me the option to to pay to upgrade
that to the PS5 copy
for like I don't know whatever 10 20
whatever the difference is
and then anytime I want to play that PS5
game I still have to put my PS4 in I
think that might be what shadowing's
talking about
so um I'm pretty sure Hogwarts Legacy
works the way that Eldon ring does let's
actually look at their let's look at
their FAQ here
see I knew I was like there's gonna be
there's so many little intricate
situations here
and different
um
okay let's see digital
now they really don't have much on the
FAQ
they do not have much in the FAQ for
that
all right so the good news is if you put
your own PlayStation store though
anything you wanted to cancel and change
over
you can do that because it's
um it was pre-ordered more than 14 days
before the release
Alicia bought PS4 physical deluxe from
the game collection
PS4 physical Deluxe
from I'm not sure what you mean by game
collection
oh JP says you can't access it at the
same time as the PS5
hmm I don't know that they've ever said
that
now I I still I told the story about
Eldon ring I obviously never tried Elden
ring like running both at the same time
but the way I understood it is that you
get like you get the full like you get
the free you would get two versions
essentially
and it is only the digital Deluxe yes
yes yes that's correct daily that is
correct
pre-ordered through Steam for the PC
generally you are good to go then you
are good to go on launch day
good to go on launch day for sure Jake
what's up my friend Jake welcome to the
Stream
uh Ashley says Xbox is the same way you
get both versions but can only play on
one or the other because of your Xbox
account I'm guessing PlayStation is the
same way
[Music]
Metro's oldest is up no this then I
wouldn't I wouldn't joke about that
I wouldn't joke about that no you're a
wizard yeah he he he's hardly ever
missed any school but he's missed two
days this week and we still
I don't know if he's gonna be able to go
back tomorrow either he hasn't had a
fever today but he's still just like
totally totally out of it
all had some sort of stomach book going
around yeah it's been it's been a lot
going around here too Phantom draws
Brittany literally can't find a PS5
anywhere okay yeah that's a good
ps5s guys they are way more readily
available now I don't know where
Brittany might be somewhere different
but in the U.S they are pretty regularly
available especially on that site we
were just on Playstation Direct
um I mean I see them pop in all the time
now in fact I actually pulled it up on
stream one time and said guys if you
want a PlayStation here you go
all right so if you if you want a PS5
they should be you know just keep an eye
on
on this website right here and see you
gotta sign in to buy
actually let me do it right now oh well
look I mean there you go there's one in
stock right now it's the god of the God
of War bundle the God of War bundle is
in stock as we speak on the PlayStation
site
all right now let me check the other one
so I'm going to sign in to buy here
and see if the uh if the other ones are
are available
because I still I feel like this is a
perception people keep saying this now
I'm not trying to sell you one on
another console if you guys don't have
the money then you gotta you gotta do
what's best for you but yeah I just
signed in and
it's available the the the disk version
is available the digital is currently
unavailable but the other day even the
digital was was in stock so yeah I mean
right there guys if you're in the US and
you're wanting a PS5
things have have certainly gotten a lot
better than they were for sure
think people wouldn't be as upset with
the delay a PS5 wasn't still so well
yeah I mean there we go
and if for people who are like if cost
is a concern there's always like I mean
the Xbox series s it's an option
that one's a lot cheaper than both the
um
that both PS5 and Xbox series X versions
got Ragnarok with my PS5 and I can
choose PS4 or PS5
yeah Ravenclaw Tyrell I think that's
that's why I'm hesitant to say much
because I think clearly some people have
experienced the other situation and then
I've experienced the the opposite
playing like Elden ring so that must be
like a game by game basis kind of thing
so I'm not I'm not 100 sure on that
if you like I think the big question is
if you could play if like you if you
could have the PS4 version up on a PS4
console running and then on another
console in the house same house you
could have the PS5 version up and
running digital I don't know or division
with another Super Chat sorry I got it
was a little late getting to that one or
division thank you so much though what's
your view on the old gen collectors
edition being laid also delayed also
that I hadn't even got to that point yet
or Division I was I was getting ready to
shift into that one
because it's uh yeah already been a
little bit a little bit spicy here so
far
some serious ass is garbage I added I
mean the series s i I think it's a great
like kind of mid-range option I don't
want to insult people who have that
system I've actually thought about
buying one for my kids like getting Game
Pass and then they're just they're just
good to go
um I haven't played it so I can't I
can't speak to it
yeah see that J Rossi like loved the
series s uh have you seen the
announcement email for tomorrow's
showcase broom clip is a little
different no I saw people posting that
in the Reddit I'm like why did I not
I'm signed up for everything Hogwarts
Legacy
um
alte alte which um if you don't mind
saying like which territory which region
are you in are you in the US or
something because
um
uh because I didn't get that at all
I'm pretty sure I'm signed up for
everything
Dylan try going to PlayStation yeah
exactly Dylan exactly that's what we
just did been receiving emails all week
brother got the PlayStation 5 from
PlayStation direct they only have the
god award dish not tonight looks like
the disc uh the regular disc was
available as well
exactly Tim that's a good point the
series s will play the game on day one
yes yes yes yes
that is I could see why people we can
since would be concerned about that with
today's announcement though I don't
think so
I think I think they're committed which
I I see that's like that's like the good
and bad right like I actually applaud
them for committing to to the last gen
version they could have very easily said
like I'm talking not recently but very
easily a year or so ago when they first
announced the the big delay they could
have very easily said
we're pushing we're we're just we're
canceling the last inversion they could
have and they didn't
so I think that's and and these are
crazy Economic Times for a lot of people
right so if you don't have the money I
mean like like Britney just said I can
eat or I could get a PS5
exactly like sadly that is that's the
situation that um
that situation for a lot of people you
know
and so I I feel for the people who had
it pre-order for PS4 and Xbox One
who don't have the money to upgrade and
also like
like for the spoilers some of the the
Discord mods we were talking about this
today
that's that's probably the most
unfortunate part about all this is like
now there's this period of time where
it's going to be very awkward for people
following the game because I mean like
like YouTube if if I was like I'm not
gonna post any spoilers on my YouTube
when the game comes out until it's out
on PS4 and and gosh I mean switch
there's no way you could wait that long
you'd be left in the dust in terms of
all the content
but it's gonna be really weird on like
live streams and stuff because roughly
well let's see let's take a look at our
poll if you haven't voted in our poll
yet I'll keep it up for about 30 more
seconds
um we've got 520 votes in this poll oh
my gosh you guys holy cow which platform
do you plan to play Hogwarts Legacy on
so 79 of you are next gen which means
you'll be able to play or current chin
rather so you'll be able to play day one
that's PS5 Xbox series X or S and PC so
all those are day one uh then 19 PS4 and
Xbox One and then two percent I can't
believe the switch is so low
I can't believe it's so low
that that version I am surprised they
haven't outright canceled like now I
mean I feel like we're good now I'm
talking about
weeks and weeks and weeks ago
um
wow 79 percent
current gen 19 last in and then two
percent switch all right I'm gonna go
ahead and end the poll
in the poll
Rodrigo Franco I love this I love this
comment
all right I'm re I'm reading it now
Rodrigo don't you know don't read into
the the chuckle right there wings of the
bats fur of the beagles if you're the
next guest
give us a little giggle
I'm not the next guest
I'm not the next guest
um at least I'm not I haven't been you
know nothing to announce
had nothing uh nothing to say at this
time
I think Rodrigo's talking about the uh
gameplay showcases
which is which is the good news we're
gonna get to that we're gonna get to the
good news
oh let's see well Hogwarts Legacy
including us include a slider to change
the size of the puddles I doubt it
Dominic I guess I'm the only one still
going to GameStop for games
oh okay I'm gonna get caught up with
chat and then we're gonna get we're
gonna talk about ore division's
questions here ps5s are not sold out
Lauren they're not sold out I literally
just pulled it up
maybe I did we have them sell out by me
pulling it up on stream
that'd actually be kind of hilarious I
don't think there's that many people
here
who are going to buy it like right now
here we go Lauren they're not sold out
this is the uh well unless you're in
another territory this is U.S the U.S
PlayStation store right now this is this
is live this is not a third party seller
God of War Ragnarok bundle or the the
PS5 version right there
yeah
little picket eight kids going in hard
on a new console oh my goodness
pineapple Sam says pretty sus
or division or uh Dr Sherbert I heard
again I giggled before yes before I read
it aloud I did
but after I read it there was no Giggle
there was no Giggle uh the white wolf
I'm guessing they thought about delaying
both gins
what do you guys think about that let me
know in the comments I saw I think it
was
I think it was nightly nerd who said
they should have delayed them all I saw
Ben snow say they agreed
they should have delayed all of them I
saw other people say no this was the
right call what do you guys think
should they have just delayed all the
versions
I'm actually gonna disagree I'm gonna
say no they shouldn't have
I'm gonna say they shouldn't have I
think they made the right call by
bringing out the uh
and because there was already some
sentiment within the fandom anyway that
oh my gosh you know they when they when
we first had the big delay I wonder if
if last gen is holding them back if
that's kind of preventing it
I think they made the right call but but
I I get it I do get I get both sides of
that
Ultra Blue says they should have delayed
it all not just for a few
I mean you guys saw the numbers just
here in our stream alone 79 so you guys
are saying for 79 of the of the player
base
or they should they should have delayed
it for
they should have kept 79 of people you
have to wait
now of course who knows what it actually
is if we I'd love to see the big numbers
one day right like once the game comes
out how many players are playing on each
system
that's a great Point too Todd they have
information we do not have Todd says I'm
wondering if they made the decision
based on the pre-orders if a majority
were next gen they figured the backlash
would be minimal
that that's a great point they have
access to data we do not have
grabbed a series X myself Dino says good
timing actually Xbox One is creaking uh
oh
beginning a demo if so when uh demo
would be cool
when expecto go and I were watching the
game awards we thought there was a
moment where Jeff said there's gonna be
a demo dropping tonight could you
imagine dude if they dropped a Hogwarts
Legacy demo could you imagine
switch ports for newer games are almost
always disasters
I still have so many questions about the
switch version Justin so many so many so
many questions
so many questions I still want to know
if it's a cloud version or not I want to
know I want to know
foreign
I go to GameStop that's where I
pre-order Hogwarts legacies PS4 Nintendo
switch but I'm happy the game yeah I
feel like
already a lot of the switch people are
like yes we finally have a date and then
PS4 people are just like Xbox One people
no
no
Jacob says no awful awful Artful says no
this is on the question of should they
have delayed all of them
pay just as much money for my system as
anyone in the new gins
I hate money hungry Humanity
I mean it money is a huge part of it for
sure but it but when it comes to
technology it's just like
there comes a point where that that the
older technology
it's just like the games that are coming
out currently are so far beyond what
they were that that you let you have to
move on as a as a uh as an industry
but you know that's the good thing about
games that aren't digital you know I
still love playing
um my wife has her original Super
Nintendo and so every now and then you
know like just very rarely but every now
and then we'll some friends and I will
pull that out and and play some of those
old games
uh TG says right call cursed bark says
no
Psalm says I would be upset if they do
just move on at this point it's been
three years three years yeah imagine if
they delayed
them I feel like Nintendo Graphics is
gonna be bad we'll see right we'll see
Clint right call Ravenclaw Terrell don't
think so Dominic absolutely not
pineapple Sam no
I think they made the right choice no
affection is ready it shouldn't be held
back by previous L1 I do feel it would
have been less controversial if they
delayed it for all
would it though what it
then everybody's mad today
not everybody I mean I think by and
large people understand that
sometimes the games just aren't ready
but this one's already been delayed a
couple times River clots are all think
it was a good call to release this way
might have had more canceled orders if
they delayed it all Lauren says yes they
should have Chris is no
uh Johnny false advertising
WB wouldn't let them delay all of it
[Music]
half of bread is better than a loaf they
made the right call
it is a really tough spot Psalm it is
yeah
[Music]
feathers what is up feathers welcome
welcome
we're getting ready to quote one of your
tweets feathers here in just a moment
or division with another Super Attack
gotta leave I'll be on replay good night
all or division thank you so much for
all the support and I just realized we
didn't even get to uh
I didn't get to your other question
I'm so sorry or division we were just
about to talk about that one though
uh will it work on the Xbox One S
um the Xbox One version right
yeah so you won't you won't it won't be
available on uh see like what do we even
call it now it won't be available on
launch day uh it'll be in April April
white wolf I'm right there with you I
agree with you I think that is indeed
the main controversy
and I would even go so far as to say and
this gets into or division's question
here the collector's edition
you guys remember they sold Collector's
Editions for
the PS4 version and the Xbox One version
[Music]
and one of the benefits
deluxe edition game and content
is the 72-hour Early Access
I feel like
a good business practice would be
refunding part of that
I do
but then see here's here's the crazy
part of it then if you start if you get
into the weeds there
then they have to put a price on it
right
then they have to put a price on what is
how much is the Early Access worth
and that's where it gets really hairy
because then people start calculating oh
wait the Early Access is worth that much
so then well then the Onyx hippogriff is
worth this and the potion and then the
dark arts pack so then wait you're
telling me the book is worth this much
it gets really weird so if they were to
do anything I think they will give away
some other sort of digital wizard item
as a as a gesture of Goodwill I I
definitely think they should that
something should be done yeah
something should be done
if you guys remember
this is on a much grander scale but when
Nintendo launched the 3DS
what did it launch at 250 or 299
I can't even remember what it wants I
gotta look this up now
um 3DS ambassador program
Nintendo launched the 3DS and it was at
a price that saw a pretty a pretty rapid
price drop
Elwyn with the Super Chat Elwyn thank
you so much for the support and the
Super Chat Chris also thank you for
subscribing to the channel uh elwin said
if they delayed it for everyone at least
it would be mad together as a community
not to find it I know right everybody's
a little divided right now and it's it's
not a good place to be in that's
probably why we're getting a showcase
tomorrow right so it's like okay let's
bring everybody back together here
poor Chandler Community managers like
stay calm everyone stay calm uh so the
3D this 3DS ambassador program this was
crazy
this was for people who purchased the
3DS before August 12th uh before that
price drop
and what Nintendo did so obviously they
did they couldn't go and refund
everybody the difference
and they didn't want to handle like Mass
returns because I guess it had been too
long for that
um but what they did is they had this
thing called the ambassador program
and gave people 20 retro games
what were the Retro I'm gonna see if we
can find I mean they were actually some
some good games too Metroid Fusion
that's right zeldominished cap oreoland
4. so I mean they were some some good
titles on there Legend of Zelda for the
NES games
so they gave and as far as I know I
think those 20 games I think that was
the only way they were ever made
available
so I do feel like I feel like something
should be done especially for when when
this is billed as a benefit right I mean
like that's that's part of the cost of
the
Collector's Editions
now we should point out that
oh my gosh see the pricing was so weird
too right the pricing of the deluxe
editions PS4
and PS5 were the same
because you you got both versions
but for the standard edition the last in
consoles were cheaper
so they were already a little bit
cheaper but then the collector's edition
was that one a little I think that one
was a little bit like 10 bucks cheaper
too or something I think so
well I will definitely be live streaming
it
I have to live stream it now if there
are people out there who who do not you
know don't want to wait who are on the
last gen or previous gen versions and
want to know what happens we're
definitely gonna have to live stream it
for sure
Ultra Blue hey thanks for hanging out
Ultra Blue have a good night
uh yes Ahoy Shiloh X will will it still
be coming out on the 7th 10th for the
Xbox series SX PS5 and PC that's correct
that's correct
I think you're right Ryan I could see
this being one of the last AAA games to
support last gym yeah and this gen kind
of stuck around longer than any other I
think because the consoles were
admittedly hard to find for a while they
were
it's getting better it's gotten better
it's still nowhere near like you can't
walk into a a Walmart Target Best Buy on
the regular and find find ps5s but we're
getting closer we're getting closer so I
think that was part of the reason that
Bastion stuck around a little bit longer
I mean you saw it even with first
parties
like even Sony a lot of their first
party stuff they're still
like Horizon God of War those were all
running on PS4 as well
very great point with the pricing idea
if they did refund some yeah
they should refund 100 well I mean if
you want 100 refund you can get that
uh so sorry
yeah you can get 100 refund
they put that on the um it depends on
region and retailer but we just we just
checked it for PlayStation and with
digital
um yeah you just I'm assuming I know
Microsoft usually has pretty friendly
policies as well and I know steam does
in terms of uh
pre-orders but we didn't actually look
up the Xbox policy but I'm I know
Microsoft has always had
pretty good return policies so yeah I
mean you you should definitely be able
to get 100 refund and if you pre-order
through a retailer
hard copy I mean 100 you can get a
refund
Amazon Best Buy Target you know GameStop
all those places you can get refunds for
sure
ah
let's see here happy don't have to worry
about PC getting pushed back I do feel
kind of bad right I mean it it
it's sad for the whole Community when
people are gonna get left behind
yo Jake what is up my friend Jake with a
1.99 super chat hey you might want to
play kahoot about Hogwarts Legacy
oh my
Jake thank you so much for the support
thank you for the Super Chat uh White
Wolf says Microsoft for pre-order will
be 100 yeah I I thought so yeah
uh Shadow guided yeah so far all we've
really been talking about is the chat
wanted to do bad news first
so we started with the bad news which is
just it's primarily this tweet right
here
so a slight delay
for people playing on PS4 and Xbox One
and then if you're on the switch this
could be good news bad news I don't know
a lot of switch people just wanted to
know the date so July 25th is the date
for switch
um the delay I mean this part's
unfortunate it is it is
um but the the part that we were really
diving into here is the Early Access
piece
The Early Access piece and how that was
you know that was mentioned as a benefit
wait where was I right here
as mentioned as a benefit still listed
on the website as being a deluxe edition
perk and it's also a perk of the of the
300 collector's edition
whatever uh I think it was like what was
it 280 290 or something for for the last
gen
you should just make a quidditch
exclusive for old [ __ ] oh my gosh laughs
oh
oh my goodness the Quidditch ambassador
program
for last gen only could you imagine
could you imagine
well but hey that both consoles are back
back compatible so
PS5 and Xbox series X and S wouldn't be
wouldn't be left out
all right all right I've had enough of
the sad I've had enough of the sad and
fortunate
let's get to the good stuff oh wait we
had a Super Chat jump in from zutara
babe09 or wait I think it's zooturababe
zutara babe or zutara Bobby
I remember you told me one time and I'm
probably pronouncing it
incorrectly my apologies but thank you
so much for that Super Chat first I
can't get tickets to Taylor Swift and
now I have to wait until April Bay
Hogwarts Legacy I just can't catch a
break oh that's unfortunate
my sister dude she is a huge Taylor
Swift fan and somehow she got tickets
somehow she got tickets I I've been
hearing about I've only followed it very
Loosely but I've heard Heard lots of
people talking about how difficult it
has been to get tickets
I've heard people talking about that
okay so let's move to the good news
because there's a lot of good news
all right so wait time stamp
hour 15 minutes in I gotta remember that
that's when I we're switching over to
the good news now guys time for the good
news
all right so the first bit of good news
um actually let me pull up a different
tweet
from our buddy Chandler wood
uh where is it where is it where is it
right here so when this news first came
out about the PS4 and Xbox One A lot of
people are like oh my gosh does this
mean
are they gonna delay the other ones too
eventually no Chandler coming in
reinforcing Hogwarts Legacy is still
launching on February 10th and on PS5
Xbox series X and S I hate that naming
scheme and PC in fact we've gone gold on
those platforms
this was the big news drop right here
for those of you who don't know what
going gold means we'll talk about that
in a second we need a bit more time in
the PS4 and Xbox One however we also
finally have a date players
um so going gold I I tweeted about this
today and there were a lot of people
saying what does going gold mean so
going gold is a term used in the gaming
industry
when
hold on hold on hold on
Community member feathers right here
feathers thank you for responding I saw
expect to go retweeted this so I was
like this is a good way of summing it up
I'm going to retweet this as well
so feathers I I know feathers was here
hanging out in the chat earlier
here you go going gold means the game is
at a level of polish that they can start
copying it onto disks and start
distribution basically confirms no more
delays they're definitely not done
fixing bugs yes that's a very very
important point there will be a day one
patch which they also mentioned in the
FAQ
let me do a control F here
so right here those who purchase a
physical copy of Hogwarts Legacy will be
required I think that's interesting that
it will be required to connect to the
internet to install a day one patch so I
guess you can't even play the game
without installing that patch
it's definitely how it sounds right
there those who purchase the game
digitally will receive the patch with
the initial download
um and then the rest of feathers his
response here there will be a day one
patch oh yeah we read that completely
eliminating all bugs is nearly
impossible true true
so yeah going gold means that discs are
starting to be printed
which is super exciting
super exciting Hogwarts Legacy like the
shipping process guys is beginning it is
getting started the discs are being
created
they're being what is it stamped is that
what you call it like where the the disc
actually gets the little artwork on it
the boxes all that stuff
is beginning to happen I mean it's
already been beginning to happen but now
confirmation from community community
manager Chandler wood saying that this
Hogwarts Legacy has officially gone gold
so that's uh that's a great piece of
good news right there the fact that the
game has gone gold
we are indeed so close it's crazy day
one patch 100 gigs right
oh goodness
yo retro guy gaming
thank you so much tier one member here
for three months a member of House
raconteur retro guy gaming thank you so
much for being here hanging out always
see your name in the comments on the
videos as well which we did post a new
video today by the way guys all about
that jump button and what it means for
Hogwarts Legacy
uh Atomic dub man hey I remember seeing
your name in the uh on the videos today
as well do I think people are
overreacting well we move we're moving
past the bad news Atomic done man we
just got finished talking about no I'm
not gonna say people are overreacting
because it's you know
if I only I mean we had we had people
just here in the chat talking about
like they've pre-order for their kids
and they were expecting to be able to
play the game on launch and you know
it's it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate and it makes like if to
elwyn's point about if it all would have
been delayed we all would have been in
the same boat like unhappy together
it does like divide the fan base a bit
um which
I don't know about you guys but like
this experiencing this game and the lead
up to this game has been such a
like Community Driven experience
where we've all been in this together
you know and so that is uh that's a
little a little divide that's being
thrown into the community there because
now
for those people who really don't want
any spoilers
they have to make sure they avoid
spoilers like they're just gonna have to
stop
they won't be able to watch live streams
uh it's going to be hard to interact on
on reddits and Discord
um I mentioned earlier our moderators on
Discord we were talking today to try to
figure out how do we
how do we kind of manage this as a
community because we're very protective
of spoilers here like I still I don't
even talk about the trophy list that has
leaked uh I don't talk about that on
live streams because we're we're trying
to protect the people who want to go in
completely blind I've talked about it in
a video that you know where it's all
clearly marked and labeled
but yeah so I I get people's
frustrations I do I do and and I I
empathize with it man
I empathize with it
so
yeah but I but but on the flip side I
mean on the flip side I I get
avalanche's position too like they
the game's not ready they they don't
want to release the last gen versions in
a in a broken State
um or I should say broken in a state
that they're not pleased with the level
of Polish
and so they they had a choice to make
right like do they delay all of them do
they delay every version for the sake of
the last gen and switch version
that that may have been discussed I'm
sure it was on the table
um and they they ultimately elected not
to do that which which I I feel like was
the right decision
but I get I get people saying that they
should have delayed them all I do I get
it so yeah I would never tell any you
know I wouldn't say people are
overreacting no no
but the important thing to remember
there's been a lot of talk earlier in
the in the in the negative section of
our discussion tonight about about
refunds and all that like
money shouldn't I mean money shouldn't
be any sort of issue in terms of like
we checked PlayStation we had people
confirm for Xbox I know it's the case on
Steam
anybody who wants a refund you you
should be able to get a refund no no
problems no problems
but we're moving to the positive news
we're focusing on the positive now
who said I don't want bugs eliminated
somebody said I don't want bugs
eliminated
feathers another Channel member member
of House wreck and tour here thanks for
the shout out a bit late today been
celebrating my birthday yo Happy
Birthday feathers
happy birthday
no more delays right right the game has
officially gone gold
yeah going gold is a big deal 100
percent
100 a big deal and uh
yeah it does feel a little bit earlier
right we're because we're December a lot
of us were guessing like early January
somewhere in there
day one patch happens with every big
every big game for sure zodiac I feel
like excitement growing as we get closer
to really same same and and tomorrow
tomorrow is going to be a big day
that's our next bit of uh of good news
guys
that is our next bit of good news
actually I don't know about anyone else
I have to play Hogwarts Legacy with my
rainbow claw robon and wand in my wand
pocket I love it
I love it
two months of avoiding spoilers as well
be annoying yeah that's I think that's
the most frustrating part that like have
to avoid spoilers and then the the
72-hour Early Access for the people who
bought the collectors and or
digital Deluxe yeah
yep yep yep
Dominic thank you for the community this
is created I can't geek out with my
friends they don't understand how big of
a deal this game is right you're welcome
here Dominic we know we know
also for any of the you others wanting
to if you're not part of the Discord yet
exclamation point Discord people hanging
out talking about Hogwarts like C and
other games all throughout the days and
weeks
[Music]
Shadow guided they should have announced
this before Black Friday so more people
could buy consoles for a good price
I'm gonna say they didn't know
I I I'm just gonna say they didn't know
maybe they did this is not obviously
it's not gonna be an easy thing to
announce you have to figure out the
timing of it right
[Music]
Ryan retro do you think 20 of the
community will disappear from YouTube
and Discord for two months no not that
much
definitely some but not that much I
think there there's a lot of people who
don't care about spoilers and will just
watch anyway
and then there's a lot of people who do
care yeah
but I feel like especially with the live
streams those first couple days weeks
are going to be interesting because so
many people are going to be playing the
game
so
it's like do you want to stop playing
the game to watch somebody else play
about the game or talk about the game
yeah I need to I don't even know what
what my live streaming schedule is going
to look like around the launch of the
game I don't because I mean I mean that
man we're gonna have to be pumping out
so many videos around that time
Nico if there isn't a mod to replace the
goblins with Shrek I will Riot right
uh I think so Dominic yeah
I think maybe with apologies potion is
my guess but I've been Mike Mike's
lately have been
I've been wrong on on my guesses lately
I said that I did not think we would
have a jump button they showed me on
that
and what else did I say
oh there was another one where I said
oh I can't remember what the other one
was
get quiet for sure not too much uh
Ravenclaw Tyrell
that's the other point little picket
yeah there's never a good time never a
good time
Draven also a good point they probably
didn't know until they went gold on on
the last on the current gin yeah yeah
place all house elves with Dobby
PS1 Hagrid mod oh you know it's gonna
happen
you know it's gonna happen
I said we had a rainbow clock opinion
uh so the Ravenclaw companion I was
talking about the one that I knew about
was a mitt yeah
that's the one I knew about
uh Alan for me it is about 9 15 p.m
about 9 15.
yo CAD Bane Bounty Hunter with a super
chat
thank you so much for the support and
showing it with uh the Super Chat there
very much appreciated so with the game
going gold and the delay a PS4 and Xbox
One to April 4th that date should be
very permanent set and sewn right
um if you if you're talking about the
February date for the current ones yeah
I think so
the other ones gosh who knows right I
mean that's not a huge delay you're
going from February 7th for Early Access
to April 4th so
right
almost right at two months
I mean I'm never gonna say set in stone
but
I feel I feel pretty confident I'd say
98 confident about the February dates
and then 95 confident about the others
so pretty confident pretty confident
EFA Spartan with a super chat as well
thank you for the support there what do
you think of steam dag I think steam
deck's awesome I've been on the fence
several times about buying one
I've been all defense several times I
keep hoping Sony will make a PS Vita too
that or call it something else I don't
know PlayStation go back to PlayStation
Portable something that would play PS5
games oh it's
it's a shame that David didn't have more
success Vita was so good but yeah I've
been on the fence a couple times about a
steam deck if I played my PC games if I
played PC more I would probably have
already bought one but will it work in
February that's a good question
I don't know enough about the PC
landscape I know Nico one of the
moderators here is a big PC Gamer so he
might know a little bit more about how
like what is the status on a lot of
newer games are a lot of them launching
with deck support just like out of the
gate
I feel like just from my
just from what I've seen
I feel like it's becoming much more
common that they're launching with with
deck support I think people clearly are
recognizing the uh
importance of the steam deck and how
well it's doing
so
I think at some point it will for sure
yeah
okay the other bit of good news
the other bit of good news and this is a
big one like I can't believe we're this
far out of the stream and we haven't
talked about this yet
if if today hadn't happened we would
have talked for three hours probably
about this alone right
so tomorrow
maybe today depending on where you're at
right now
December 14th another Journey Into The
Wizarding World awaits on December 14th
join Avalanche WB and Community guest
host
Benjamin snow for a second Hogwarts
Legacy gameplay showcase
there are rumors I don't know if you
guys saw that there was a post on the
Reddit about I don't know somebody
looked at some code on YouTube and
figured out it's supposed to be around
36 minutes long or something
so
I am happy to say
I will be live streaming this one guys I
will be like provided I'm 95 sure
provided that everything goes well at
work tomorrow I should be able to take
my lunch break
and live stream it
should be should be barring anything
crazy happening
let me actually double check my calendar
here just to make sure
yeah I think we're good I think we're
good man
so uh I probably won't be going live
until it's going to be very close to the
time that it's it's going up
um but let's see when do they even did
they not say the times in this post I
don't think they did uh but it in this
follow-up tweet they said this tune in
for a new look at broom flight and
traversal Advanced combat and an
introduction to the room of requirement
the Showcase will be hosted on Twitch
and on YouTube
so this is awesome I love that we're
getting another one of these showcases
just this clip alone here
gave us quite a few details first of all
we saw a new broom clip everybody's been
talking about the little meter down here
it looks like there's going to be a
boost somebody was asking last week if
we get to purchase like broom upgrades
or different type of brooms
seeing something like that makes me even
more
confident that we will
then also the very gosh the Twitter
compression is so bad it's not it's not
gonna look this bad tomorrow guys we're
gonna get it in glorious glorious 4K but
first of all can we talk about this mask
right here okay we talk about the eyes
what the heck's going on there Dustin
with a five dollar Super Chat
foreign
thanks so much Dustin always love seeing
your name pop up in the streams uh and
thank you for the Super Chat there
calling it during the Showcase Ben will
announce the winter ASMR will be
released soon because his last name is
snow
oh man I love his new I don't know if
it's if it's his new logo or what but I
I saw his little YouTube icon he changed
it to a snowflake
like dude that's so good I love that
such a good logo for someone named
Benjamin snow I love it
but yeah winter ASMR I still feel like I
mean they did the last one on
Thanksgiving so maybe Christmas day
maybe we get the next one
maybe maybe Christmas is always a big
moment in the Harry Potter series as
well
but yeah I hope you guys will hang out
here tomorrow I know there's a lot of
so many people who are going to be live
streaming this and you have lots of
choices of where to spend your time
uh just saying you could pull up
multiple windows you pull up multiple
windows guys nothing wrong with that
multiple windows go back and forth
listen to different people react to
different things
uh but yeah we're gonna be live all
things as long as all things go well at
work tomorrow I'm gonna be live
streaming
which I'm super excited because I did
not get to do it for the last one I had
a very important work meeting
um actually the only thing I got to live
stream Hogwarts Legacy related was the
I'm pretty sure I did the gameplay the
state of play
when they when they showed Avada Kedavra
and speaking of Avada Kedavra
you guys see this down here
actually you can't see it too well
because I'm partially cutting it off
with my little uh
my box here
it looks like a vodka diver is a
slottable spell
yeah looks like it's a slottable spell
there's so much going on in this scene
right here first off I think this is 100
the dark arts battle arena
um
we see this mask here we see the blue
eyes is this like some ancient magic
thing is this part of the Mask is this
the character changing because they've
went down the dark path
I have so many questions here
so many questions
also I think the other two I saw a
different screenshot I don't know how
people maybe if I let it play we'll see
it
oh yeah I think people must have stopped
it like right at this last frame here
no I don't know how people got the other
uh but I'm pretty sure it's Imperial oh
maybe right in there pretty sure it's
imperio and crucio as the other two and
we still aren't 100 sure what this one
is
so the unforgivable spells again oh this
is the other thing I was wrong about
feathers this is the other thing
this scene is sick it's so good right
it's so good
first of all let's talk about this too
defeat an enemy with a Chinese chomping
cabbage
it's apparently a challenge right here
oh I think it's a part of the Garrison
cosmetic Set uh is that the like the
dark arts cosmetic
oh first of all I love this this little
like transition right into the AK
so it seems that they're all slottable
and we get a little like the mountain
troll up here that pops up dude this
troll is massive by the way massive
and it's at full health so wait it's 8K
dude it instantly takes down the
mountain troll
that whole bar of Health are you kidding
me right now
6686 damage for about a Kadabra
defeat trolls two out of five
and we got a Slither in here casting the
dark magic
oh dude what do you think I should now
notice this symbol for the first time
over here on the left what do you guys
think this symbol is
like this little invalid
oh thanks Nico I just saw your message
in Discord why didn't I get that in my
email
I'm gonna have to re-sign up for
Hogwarts Legacy emails or something it
looks like a a bird
a raven an eagle an owl I'm not sure but
then it has an invalid symbol on it
zoom in please I don't think I don't
think I can on this
yeah it's not gonna let it's on Twitter
once it's on uh
once it's on
oh my gosh I can't speak once it's on
YouTube tomorrow in 4k we'll be able to
break this down a lot more but yeah
right over here
no summoning oh oh my gosh amount maybe
it's a hippogriff
or thestral maybe
saying you can't summon in this area
it means no ravenclaws oh my gosh maybe
you can't send mail there a no-flying
symbol
believe you're not no yeah lots of
people say no Mount icons
can't escape no running from the fight
looking forward to the Cabbage only
guaranteed million plus YouTube video
right there Dustin Quist
I played through the entirety of
Hogwarts Legacy using only the Chinese
chomping cabbage
I mean million plus guaranteed
guaranteed
have a good night Shadow guided thank
you for being here
oh James has a post on his community tab
yeah I saw several people had it posted
but I'm like where do they get this
I don't know where they got
where they got these without the T logo
in front of it
hippogriff not a griffin
I mean well I'm not even gonna pretend
to guess what to me honestly more than
anything it looks like an eagle or Raven
from this little shot right here but
it's all blurry and small so
can't fly in the area I think I think
that's probably it yeah
it's at the very start of the clip
I mean the only time I see it is right
as it's kind of ending
foreign
PM Eastern 10 a.m Pacific 6 p.m GMT 7 PM
CET those are the times
those are the times for tomorrow which
you can watch it right here
live as we break it down
oh yeah I'll pull that up Nico
I don't know where people got that but
I have no idea where people got it
but I shall pulled up here Nico coming
in clutch guys this is gonna be a much
better picture to look at here
all right so let's see here direct
messages
here we go
thank you Nico appreciate it
foreign
I'm late tonight guess I'll be part of
the replay Squad
Gabe thank you for being here hope
you're having a good night okay so
we know it's slottable we got the symbol
for it so this one's imperio we already
know that and then this now we see our
symbol for crucio my gosh look at that
is that nails like oh
driven through the hand
yikes
okay so imperio lavacadabra crucio now
since we just saw that it did six
thousand something hundred damage to the
troll the next question becomes
because people are instantly saying oh
this doesn't this means it's not a
finish here
I'm still not convinced that it's not a
finisher
I'm still not convinced
the combo has reached 10 right here and
it looks like this is right after they
cast about Kadabra because we see that
the meter the button it's just
completely depleted right here so that's
why it's all darkened out and it looks
like the combo meter is draining here
too the the ancient magic meter is
draining too
combo is at 10
. so is it gonna be a super long
cooldown yeah we don't know we don't
know Jason that's exactly where I was
going to there we don't know the
cooldown
so even if it for sure slottable we see
that here confirm I think that's great
that's awesome now the question becomes
how often can you use it right what is
the cooldown like
is it tied to the combo meter
does the combo meter make it refill
faster so many questions so many
possibilities I mean there are potions
that can make it refill faster there's
gear that can make it Reef fill faster
maybe we attend classes and we upgrade
certain skills that are going to make it
refill faster
so many questions but it is slottable
just think it probably has a really long
loading time
oh Dustin that would that people will be
so bad if they pulled that if they're
like it's only for the arena maybe the
dark arts Arena only oh my gosh
it's like you could slot it here but nah
I don't think they do that I mean I
clearly think maybe there's a focus on
it here maybe it refills faster in the
Dark Arena or something
Channel until you kill possibly
uninterruptable Mel says oh so you mean
like
wait what do you mean
I I was with you for a second and then
the more I thought about it
I lost I lost it at that point
you're a wizard Harry
so we can't AKA prefect
I mean at this point Jason I'm not gonna
say
I laughed at you all for suggesting it
but I'm not gonna suggest I'm not gonna
laugh at that suggestion anymore
because maybe we can't yo house eight
minutes ago dude house I'm so sorry your
super Jack came in right after uh Dustin
I'm gonna go and Trigger this again
because I missed it before house
in the house I love that house says that
every time uh I'll be watching your
stream house thank you so much
thank you for stopping by thank you for
hanging out and uh thank you for the
Super Chat there
Draco my Planet crucial puppy is still
possible
the infinite spell points maybe you need
to hit a certain combo the see Nat
that's that's sort of what I'm thinking
which then to me means it's basically a
finisher anyway that was my idea of a
finisher was always just it's something
that you're gonna have to chain combos
you're gonna have to build up that
ancient magic meter then you can use
them
would they would they really tie in the
AK with ancient magic I don't I don't
think so
I don't think so but I could still see
it being tied to the combo somehow maybe
the combo makes it go faster
don't know don't know
cooldown sheet will be one of the first
mods right I mean I think it has to be a
long cooldown
otherwise I mean
how game breaking would that be right
look I wanted AK in there just as much
as the next person because
it opens up so many gameplay
possibilities but watch this dude just
completely I'm gonna have to refresh
this I think
watch this character here just
completely
annihilate this this mountain troll
it does
6686 damage
so his health is full right there you
guys
the health is full and AK I mean to be
like book accurate this you know
boom just just insta insta
that troll is gone it looks like he's
just standing there dude
so lots of questions about that about
how that's gonna work lots of questions
now
hold on I saw somebody asked um
oh that'd be interesting Nico maybe it's
like Comet as you're an elder and you
have to hold AK okay so for the people
who aren't don't get that reference so
the way some of the Eldon ring well all
the Eldon ring magic works is you only
have a certain number of it until you
like rest
so like let's say I I have 10 AKs and
then once I use those 10 I have to like
reset by getting out of the area maybe
using a special item to refill it or or
resting something like that right so I
think what Nico's saying is what if I
actually use it once it's like a
one-time use until you do whatever it is
in Hogwarts Legacy like in an elder ring
it's resting at the bonfires and stuff
but then there was another comment that
said um
we'll find out tomorrow I mean right we
don't have to wait long uh yogg said did
you see the new footage of broom flight
it's different from I did see it we'll
pull it up here in a second and talk
about it because uh Nico sent that to me
as well in the in the chat here but
before we get to that I wanted to talk
about this next scene right here
this right here
this right here
so they tease that we're going to be
getting more about room of requirement
which I can't wait to see this is one of
the things that when they first showed
us this blew my mind this whole
Menagerie that the vivariums all these
magical beasts it blew my mind that I
never thought they would be doing
anything like this like a lot of people
are upset that minigames aren't and
stuff like that aren't in there to me
stuff like this is an equal
like more than equal
wait yeah yeah more than equal
replacement
because I think my guess is that this is
a lot deeper than people think
a lot deeper than people think and these
icons are the first hint of it
so I'm not sure actually what the uh
so we've got this one right here I guess
is like
telling us how hungry they are
so we're gonna have to be feeding them
have to take care of them
and then you look over here our SP in
the bottom right our spells have
completely changed so R1 here is not a
pug no
this R1 pet or something what does the
R1 do
and then I guess is the heart oh we've
got male female
which
I mean does does that mean breeding
does that mean reading
not gonna I'm not gonna say much more
than that but people who have taken a
peek at the trophies
people have taken a peek at the trophies
have something to say about that so you
got that symbol here and then I guess
this heart with the paw print is that
just like a general like Health do you
guys think
desperately won a unicorn and a dragon
like Pokemon but better
says I would still enjoy playing Wizards
chess
baby Beast I mean I I'm gonna say yeah I
think the fact that we have that we've
already seen younger magical creatures
throughout I mean we saw it with grab
horns right we've seen uh families of
grab horns and I think we've seen
thestrals too right
oh what can we do if we have a lot of
pets sell
[Music]
hmm
I don't know
I don't think cell but then but then
that begs the next question right well
then what do you just you just like
breed all and you just have this entire
this vivarium filled with like more
creatures than newt scamander
I love this though I think I think this
is going to be such a big part of like
our extra stuff like the other stuff to
do that people keep asking about I think
this is going to be a big part of it
now what do you guys think about these
in the bottom right over here what's
going on down here so our spells and
again if the Twitter quality was any
better
I mean this one here on the left maybe
that's food
then at the top right we have something
that looks like a a rock a brain I don't
know what that is the only one that I
can kind of make out is this one right
here at the bottom that looks like a
goblet with either a drink or a potion
in there and then this one's like arrows
left and right and then R1 we have this
little paw print symbol right there Noob
with another Super Chat Noob always
showing love and support here thank you
so much Noob we can't sell them poppy
we'll take our souls right
oh dude maybe poppy oh mate hold on hold
on Noob hold on
maybe Poppy
because Poppy's family
what was the the guy's last name or the
guy's first name Sweeting
um poppy comes from like a family who
like the the animal rights and and care
of magical creatures is very important
to him what if it's like book one where
we send them off like remember Harry
Hagrid and Norbert
you guys remember Norbert
if you've only seen the movies you're
like
you're like that was like a very quick
scene what happened to Norbert right uh
so in the books we we know what happens
to Norbert we actually see that whole
scene
um
but Norbert goes with Ron's brother
who's studying dragons
Charlie
and so what if poppy has a family member
that we send these creatures to dude
Noob what if you what if you just
what if we inadvertently just figured it
out there
so Poppy's like oh no no no you're not
selling these creatures we're gonna
breed them and we're going to I don't
know just
repopulate certain areas of the world
where these magical creatures are aren't
thriving or something I don't know
but I definitely feel like poppy will be
involved noob 100 percent
oh no comments started flying by too
quick I missed things
foreign
Rodrigo I get that a lot of people
really don't want to be spoiled by
watching all the release content but the
speculation to see it is a huge part I
mean and the stuff that they're
revealing officially I don't even
consider that being spoiled
I mean I think they're they're showing
some things that are the oh literally
the only thing I care about being
spoiled on is is story stuff like all
the mechanics everything else like spit
I don't even care about spells tell me
all the spells that are gonna be in the
game I don't care
yeah
I don't care about all that maybe
washing food pets and switch out but oh
what if like the left one's like dung
like you have to clean or something you
have to clean it up at least you're not
with the Super Chat at least or not
thank you so much I don't see a comment
with that one so I guess you're just uh
showing support of the stream thank you
very much Leisure knot thank you for
being here and hanging out
sell them to poachers oh my gosh Dustin
Dustin's gonna be the one that Poppy AKs
you guys
Dustin is going to be the one maybe we
can only rescue the baby animals
Neil wema
oh my gosh Neil we might not get romance
options but these beasts are set oh
goodness we're gonna be breeding the
magical beasts it seems like
lowercase Logan with another Super Chat
Logan thank you again for your support
the left diamond is the brush oh
okay now I feel stupid for saying maybe
it's dunk
oh my gosh yeah I was wondering what
that was too Logan it's this I I'm you
know what i'm blaming the the Twitter
video compression here yeah I was like
what is this little thing hovering right
here yeah so that's the brush which we
gotta better look at in the other
uh state of Play trailer so yeah I think
Logan is spot on right here this is the
brush and then I think it's this icon
right here on the left
yeah you can see just barely that the
bottom is kind of a slightly different
color slightly different color and then
like kind of the handle on top here
thank you Logan thank you
uh more of the leaks that oh yeah right
Jenny yeah like the trophy stuff yep yep
nerdy cat gonna pre-order the deluxe
edition very soon nice nice
so breeding for Poppy and her family I'd
rather vote yourself buy new clothes oh
my gosh
oh my gosh
Poppy's the final boss of the game
Charlie's friends come to pick up
norberta wait why is everybody calling
it norberta oh because they discover
right
wait is it hold on they discovered it
was actually female is that what happens
how am I not remembering this at all
but they don't they don't figure that
out till afterward right
uh Jay Rossi wonder if breeding feeding
animals will yield ingredients or
potions or plants fertilizer I think
definitely on the I think it will for
sure have a role to play in the plants
and fertilizer section for sure
for sure
imagine us all on February 6th
you've heard rooms that rumors that
Poppy doesn't mean to AK
H she's the there's only one person
who's been known to have survived it and
it's not Harry Potter
they said in the trailer to capture and
heal corrupted creatures right indeed
indeed
do you think we'll be able to go to
Azkaban for a little visit I hope
azkabans in the game at some point I do
I mean they showed it in that first
trailer
pretty sure that was Azkaban but then we
haven't gotten anything else about it
collecting mooncalf dung and putting on
poppy said oh my gosh Alicia
oh geez uh it'll be a good death Dustin
says wow Dustin are you Slytherin Dustin
let me guess Dustin evil Slytherin first
playthrough
maybe the other slots don't have
anything to do with the animal and it's
grayed out because you can't use it at
the moment see I I don't think any of
these are spells I think all of this is
somehow related to what we're doing here
in the room of requirement with the
animal
I think
Moon Lily that's I mean that kind of
ties into the Azkaban question how often
do you think we'll encounter the mentors
are we going to face off against them if
Patronus is not included in the game
so many things we don't know I mean I
think we can say for sure the mentors
are in
after they showed him in the first
trailer and then they they didn't talk
about them they haven't they haven't
mentioned them in anything but then
they're also on the cover for the deluxe
I feel like they got to be in there at
some point
so then to your point well if they're in
how do we combat them
I'm still not sold on the Patronus charm
not being in the game I think there's a
chance it is
I think there's still a chance it is I
don't know if it will be bringing over
from the one from The Wizarding World I
don't know that'd be like an um that
would be a very cool thing
to unveil though right that that it is
in the game
could you imagine if you get to a point
in the game and you cast your Patronus
and then all and it's actually the one
from your Wizarding World account that'd
be insane but then they would still have
to have one for people who don't link so
um or the other possibility for
combating to mentors is ancient Magic
the ancient magic is like the trump card
for anything here right they could that
could get them out of any sticky
situation okay wait
ancient magic we're gonna say we're
gonna say ancient magic can destroy the
Dementors yes
yes let's go with that
it's possible
Norbert was a female so they called her
border and they didn't did they not know
it at the beginning they didn't know it
till Charlie like sent word back or
something right
foreign
with another Super Chat Dustin thank you
so much evil Hufflepuff actually LOL
death Dustin's an evil Hufflepuff oh my
gosh loyal to the soil like the in fear
oh my goodness Dustin with the evil
Hufflepuff
uh the Entertainer says food grooming
petting and interacting okay hold on
let's look at this here so oh
okay I could definitely see this one
being maybe some yeah like little I
don't know
some kind of pellets or something you've
wrapped up in a small bag or something
uh then that one's grooming for sure I
think we figured that one out and then
what'd you say for the other two
oh petting and interacting
I don't know about petting because I
feel like this would just be petting
this one I feel like is is water
like drink
and then the right one I just have no
idea
uh break plays can tell us something
about the PS4 pre-order yeah yeah sure
go ahead and post it in the chat there
brick place
Moon Lily will get a generic Patronus or
Patronus from a set list I yeah
I'm hoping Patronus is in there and that
maybe they just tie it to our characters
back like in-game backstory whatever it
is
I think that'd be cool
oh don't get me started on everybody's
awesome patronuses don't get me started
how do we combat Dementors run right a
valid option
a valid option
want to be Ravenclaw my first
playthrough but I want to companion king
of games oh my gosh
oh my gosh sad faces
sad faces in the chat
I think
you guys have a mitt come on amit's
gonna be totally cool everybody
it's gonna be awesome at least you're
not with another Super Chat at least
you're not thank you again for the sport
do you think we'll be able to name the
animals we tame
I really I hadn't thought about it but I
really hope so again like Pokemon give
them nicknames I was about to say yeah
like maybe right up here
dude it almost looks like
okay again the Twitter compression on
the video is terrible wizard but it
like there's like this gray box around
that I don't know if they're doing that
just
to make it so the um
the grab horn stands out a little bit
more but what if it actually has a name
above it
and they like just this is like they did
a quick job to edit it out or something
I hope so that I mean that shouldn't be
a very hard thing to do right to have
where you can just go in and
give them a little nickname
oh they didn't find out till book four
chamber okay that's yeah I totally not
remember that it's a deep cut right
there they found out a book for when
Haggard takes Harry to see them for the
first challenge yes
uh the one on the right is putting the
beast in and out of your bag
I could see that Dominic I could see
that
poppy is gonna be my Bellatrix Dustin
says uh Elwyn maybe one of them is you
have to keep their environment clean I
could see that
yeah lowercase Logan right could be
summoning summoning and putting them
away
arrows being the Beast jumping out of
the case that animation is just so good
it's just so good
your Patronus is seriously a slug
feathers
what
okay hold on I was trying to find
Brick's comment
it seems as though the pre-order
countdown timer is reset and is now set
for April 4th uh okay so that you did
the brick plays you did the PS4 version
right is that the one you've done
foreign
companion
Chinese chomping cabbage oh my gosh I
love what a great name sporting Patronus
this would be a great way to make up for
the game delay
all right so Hogwarts is a gameplay
showcase number two again tomorrow we're
gonna be streaming in here guys uh 1 p.m
Eastern Time 10 a.m Pacific 6 p.m GMT 7
P.M
c-e-t
and here again one more time for those
who are just joining in or who missed
the bit here so here's what they said
they're going to be covering in this one
broom flight and traversal
excuse me so now I'm wondering like are
we gonna see some thestral and or
hippogriff flight as well Advanced
combat love this love this because the
first one I was just like I have so many
more questions
after the first gameplay showcase now
we're getting a look an advanced look at
combat and an introduction to the rumor
requirement so introduction so I feel
like this one's going to leave us
wanting more
uh and then we saw little quick previews
of all of these
in the shot right here
so there you go that's tomorrow
that is tomorrow Dementors are on the
cover-up for the deluxe right exactly so
I think they're gonna be in
oh you were kidding I was I was thinking
feathers I have no yeah I didn't think
slug was an option
I did not think slug was an option
do you think our choices will have an
impact on companions will they support
us no matter if we go dark or not or
turn against us
I mean
um Alan said our choices will have an
impact
the question is just how much of an
impact
amit's gonna
be like the dollars
idiot
oh
geez
James my partner got a mole Patronus tie
twice what does that mean I I have no
idea
there are so many just obscure random
patronuses and then everybody every
stream I talk about them by the way guys
I said we're not going to talk about
them and here we go you're taking me
down this Rabbit Hole every time I'm
like oh yeah I got a a cat and I'm super
allergic to cats then here come the
comments oh I got I got a dragon I got a
thestral I got a wolf yeah I saw you I
saw you in the chat I got a wolf
I got a lion
okay we get it everybody has awesome
patronuses patronize
we're moving on now though we're moving
on
okay moving on there we go
they readjusted to April 4th oh wait
hold on I want to see Brick plays his
other comment I'm curious PS4 digital
Deluxe okay there you go so yeah it has
indeed updated
that's what I was thinking
that you would have to
I'm going to respond to that person who
tweeted me earlier because I don't know
for sure on any of those questions guys
about pre-orders I mean
it's it's so complex that even even
Hogwarts legacies FAQ like they knew
to to their credit like they knew this
was this was going to be a thing and
that people were going to have a lot of
questions
wait where did it go
oh my gosh why can I not find the links
oh because they're I was looking for the
color difference they're barely
I mean so they even here's where you
need to go PlayStation for support here
Microsoft support here or retailer where
you pre-order the game if you pre-order
the physical copies and then same for
Steam and uh epic game store
as well
need to see what PC gameplay will look
like I agree Owen I think most of what
we've seen so far has been running on a
PS5
Chris huff and puff hey Chris welcome
welcome it's been a spicy one it's been
an engaging one very interesting stream
tonight we've had we started off with
the bad news now we've shifted into good
news talking all about tomorrow's
gameplay showcase which we will be
streaming live here guys
right here youtube.com retro raconteur
now I also want to pull up you guys were
talking about the other clip
let me go to the one Nico sent so
apparently this email which
been covering this game for literally
years they're not saving me I don't know
why
oh after I just like I don't know maybe
I opted out by accident at some point no
I wouldn't have opted out
I don't know why I'm not getting it
though
I don't think anyone ever answered my
question about which uh
which territories
okay
all right how do I
I'm trying to figure out how I can
pull this up here
so you guys can see it
okay wait here we go this should work
okay so here
's the other flying clip
that they sent out to tell people to get
ready for the Showcase very very short
unless it's longer than oh yeah it's
email so it probably was indeed short
so slightly different clip than what we
saw before on the flying
and just like
just flying around this world going to
all the different little
regions and outposts and whatever else
we can find on our journey I can't wait
man I can't wait Advanced combat right
I'm so pumped about
that's probably the thing I'm pumped
about the most
Mr Vettel I bought the PS4 plus PS5
Deluxe my PS5 Library countdown timer
says 55 days two hours four minutes
see that like there we we get into the
complex part of it right like depending
on where you pre-ordered from
and depending on
like it's even different whether you
pre-ordered from the console or from the
website is what I I mean that's I think
that's what I'm hearing from people
maybe it was only in Canada for the new
clip I don't think so but I yeah I don't
I don't think I got it
yeah see Hannah there you go there's
Hannah Hannah jumping in with the
thestral Patronus
Chris I'm excited about the Showcase
bummed I bought a PS4 just to play on
February 7th oh see that's the other
tough part man when people bought the
console specifically
for
uh someone earlier was saying it would
have been great if we could have found
out like before all the Black Friday
sales and stuff true true true
if emit Chronicles our story Legend what
if we could potentially die like in
Dragon Rossi spoilers
just kidding I'm just kidding Jay Rossi
Dragon Age Origins spoilers apparently
dude okay though for real like we know
I think I think it was on Alex when
podcast now was joining with I think it
was when he had been on they were
talking about
at some point there had been so many
live streams at this point but somebody
was talking about
whatever happens in Hogwarts Legacy
right
there has to be a point where
either somehow people forget or for some
reason it isn't passed on like we we're
gonna be an important character but we
can't be that important of a character
right because then the cannon and all
gets kind of weird I I think there are
ways around that but one interesting way
around that would be
if our character dies like Jay Rossi
says there
so that's why we never
became important in The Wizarding World
let's see can anyone else believe it's
less than 60 days away right James
amazing dude amazing
uh Davis so the last gen versions have
gotten a delay to April so PS4 and Xbox
One
any Theory cloud-based Hogwarts Legacy
game for the switcher actual Port I've
been saying cloud
I I've been saying cloud
now I've seen all the evidence to the
contrary like people talking about the
boxes and all that I've seen I've seen
the evidence say otherwise but like I
just I just can't imagine I just can't
imagine this game running on the switch
honestly natively
maybe if everything's at 30 FPS and then
you know the switch I think I think
undocked it only runs at 7 20. so I I
don't know I don't know maybe they can
turn the settings down enough it's not
coming out till July we learned today
July 25th I think it was for the switch
release yeah until until I hear
otherwise I'm Still rocking with the um
that it's going to be a cloud-based
version yeah
that's my guess
but I've been wrong lately I've been
wrong on a couple things lately so
a mass obliviate after you saved the
world I know Mel I hope they don't pull
the same thing as a
Fantastic Beasts
you sent the timer and on Twitter okay
sounds good yeah I
yeah I'm pretty sure brick that's
correct like if you pre-order the PS4
version that
that one's gonna get pushed the digital
one so
Ravenclaw thoughts which was going to be
like November December
try this one out nobody remembers us or
talks about us because we use Ancient
magic we know they've always hid
anything away to do it thank you yeah I
mean like if something happens at the
end where we decide the secret it has to
be kept a secret or something
Ashley I wonder if we have other
companions other than the four we have
now or if we can bring other students
along other than them
or if the story takes us to a specific
person right because in most RPGs action
RPGs once you like sort of build up your
party
there's only a certain number that you
can take with you
and then you can kind of pick and choose
we have no idea in this I think for sure
we're going to have at least some story
missions like we've seen oh my goodness
didn't mean to hit the mic there hope
that wasn't too loud for you guys we've
even seen that like fig is accompanying
us on some of the missions
so I feel like his like that one might
be set right like on this Mission it's
fig who's gonna be with you
but then I feel like there should also
be other missions where it's left a
little bit more open
to where maybe you can pick one or two
or however many I don't know
but I think it's a good question
a very very good question
Usman what have you planned for the
future after Hogwarts Legacy so
still thinking about it I mean obviously
we're going to be covering a lot of
Hogwarts Legacy stuff for the whole year
because I mean the game's gonna stay I
think people are gonna be interested in
it for at least the first six months of
the year and then probably another
little uptick around the switch release
but we'll certainly start covering more
games I think for sure our live streams
we're still going to do live streams
they'll probably be more you know we're
not just going to talk about Hogwarts
Legacy every time
um but we'll kind of shift a little bit
to talk do more gaming news in general I
have some video ideas though that I'm
gonna be
I'm gonna be uh testing out on the
channel to see how they go and then I'm
hoping I know people have been here for
a long time they hear me say this a lot
but at some point I am hoping to bring
back more regular
um like actual gaming streams most
likely over on Twitch when we do that
man I appreciate that question though
lots of people been asking that
and uh James and I expect to go I've
been talking about that too you know
kind of like like what's next you know
and I know there's going to be a lot of
people who move on and and that's okay
right that's okay I hope some of you
will stick around
make sure you're part of the Discord
though exclamation point Discord
anything that we
anything we do will at some point be
posted over there for sure you also have
the uh uh I'm on Twitter as well at
retro raconteur
just subscribe to McGuire thank you so
much for subscribing welcome
oh yeah Dustin already gave me a
guaranteed one million plus video you
know
looking forward to that one
Chinese chomping cabbage only play
through I hope that's possible dude I I
hope that's possible now and then think
about all the other obscure things in
the game
all the other obscure things
oh man some there was some comment right
now that just reminded me of a comment I
saw
before the stream even started
and I said I really want to make sure I
reply to that comment and I totally
forgot it was it was a really I was like
oh that's such a good comment I want to
answer that question
I might have to go back and like
re-watch the uh
the VOD where I can see the different
comments popping in
anyway okay sorry that was random
laughs
many of us love to join streams and play
the game as we hear the stream I don't
think the community go no no no moon
they won't they won't but I mean it's
it's um
what's the word for it it's like it will
be the end of an era of a specific era
for sure like this has just been a very
fun
journey in the build up now if it was a
multiplayer game
this it wouldn't be nearly as much like
this you know but where it's a single
player only game now there's obviously
there's the hope for a future DLC
there's the hope for a sequel at some
point
so you know there's still lots of things
to kind of hope for also maybe uh Harry
Potter what is it
not Hogwarts mystery but um magic
awakened maybe that one will finally
release
for uh for all of us here in the UK or
here in the U here in the US and the UK
uh Vincent we we covered we covered all
the bad news uh early so you have to you
have to hit the VOD for that one we chat
voted to take bad news first so we did
bad news then we moved to the good news
so we've been talking about the uh the
upcoming gameplay showcase tomorrow
should be a lot of fun should be a lot
of fun with lots of new things
lots of new things in store and we're
gonna be streaming it here live so hope
to see some of you guys here
don't know whether to be happy or sad
dude there's this song
for any of you who were around for the
Harry Potter
um
just like the birth of that fandom and
the rise of that fandom there is a song
written by a group a wizard rock group
called Oliver Boyd and the remembralls a
song called um I think it's end of an
era
I think the name of the song is end of
an era
oh my goodness ma'am
you want to go on a nostalgic trip
go pull up that video and watch it
and have your tissues handy
because I I think about that song
when I think about like this build up to
Hogwarts Legacy oh man I do Christ I
love that song So Good
they also have a song called just to
help yeah they uh they had a lot of uh
songs that they wrote during the wizard
Rock era I think they had a lot anyway
but that one it is just stuck with me
for so long I just I went and watched it
the other day several times I'll
probably watch it after the stream
tonight I would play it right now if I
wasn't afraid it would get um
the copy a copyright strike not a strike
but a uh
oh my gosh what's it called claim
copyright claim but yeah
pull up that video pull up that song
listen to it oh yeah for sure elwin yes
yes yes I remember the Potter Puppet
Pals
oh we just got news today that's right
Draven the open Beta globally they've
said very soon yeah
but they they've said soon so many times
I'm like what
that's that's you guys need to look up
the definition of soon it's not that's
not sued
that's not soon
got a little Potter Puppet Pals action
going on in the chat oh my gosh those
are some of my favorite videos some of
my favorite videos
off topic but the making of the music
video got me more hyped for the game
than anything else oh my gosh it's so
good
it's so good
#soon right
there you go Nico oh it's so good man
it's so good
I might have to I'll have to play it at
some point on a stream and I don't know
just edit it out later YouTube does give
you a little feature where you can go
back in and and clip things out
deluxe edition for Xbox One S indeed
yeah
well no you you get it February 7th
you'd get the Early Access Christopher
on Xbox or no no no no no no no no no
I'm sorry I'm sorry Xbox wait did you
mean Xbox series s
oh my gosh that naming scene if you
meant Xbox one that one will also be
delayed yeah yeah
that one's also delayed
foreign
I'm so sorry wait what
Mrs raconteur
that's my wife's name on Twitch I'm like
wait is she in the chat
do you think we'll be able to sit down
in couches
um I do yeah yeah I do Michael
we see a little dot that shows up
in the area that Boston called the Hub
of the castle
right next to that Fountain we see a
little dot around the bench there that
shows up
I think so yeah
most excited for the Showcase tomorrow
that's a good one
oh
it's a good one but it's a tough one
so here's here's what they've said we're
getting Bloom flight and traversal
Advanced combat and an introduction to
the room of requirement
I mean I'm excited about all three of
them can't lie but if I had to pick just
one
I would I think I'm gonna say Advanced
combat like I really want to know more
about the combat and how it works
I really want to know more about that
but I'm I am truly excited about all
three pieces for sure
for sure
anyone remember the OG Potter Puppet
Pals before The Mysterious Ticking Noise
I'm sure I remember some of them yeah
Dustin Advanced combat for me unless
breeding and selling to poachers is
confirmed with the room of requirement
bit oh my gosh
I just like I want to know more about
how the Avada cadaver works I want to
know more
think we'll see outside of the announced
agenda uh probably not much honestly
I feel like they'll pretty closely stick
to that but that's a lot of I mean
there's a lot they could show right with
um
like broom flight and traversal like
traversal that on its own that's a wide
range of things they could cover
and then introduction to the room of
requirements so I said earlier I feel
like that means they're just going to
show us a little taste we're going to be
left wanting more it's my guess
um and then Advanced combat so we've
already seen a little bit about combat
and now they're going to be expanding on
that more
so yeah I mean I don't feel like much
more than that but as you guys know with
it being I think the rumor on Reddit was
uh 35 36 minutes or so you know there's
going to be so much that we're going to
be dissecting and breaking down and
finding in there
they could show one of the challenges
yeah
foreign
man it is 10 15 p.m we've been trying to
get to about two hours
like I said I've been feeling a little
under the weather today and I can feel
my I can feel my energy fading so
um I'm gonna try to get up early
tomorrow get get some work done for my
real job and then hope to have
everything ready to roll so I can take
my lunch break to live stream
the gameplay showcase ladies and
gentlemen happening tomorrow uh again 1
p.m Eastern Time
I think it was tanning in Pacific
so we will be streaming it here hope to
see you all there
and thank you guys for the support
tonight man lots of new Subs lots of new
members joining the stream as well
um I'm gonna put up a poll so if you
guys aren't sub wait hold on actually
let me just pull it up here because I
don't know
I don't know if the YouTube
Community section shows up for everyone
without you
going directly in here so if you guys go
to my main YouTube channel youtube.com
retro record will get you here and then
go to the Community page I'm going to
put up a poll here that you guys can
vote in for the date for our Christmas
celebration
um I'm not quite ready to announce all
the details just yet we're almost
finalized but I wanna I wanna get a I
want to see where things shake out for
the date so the possible dates are going
to be next Tuesday the 20th that is
possible date number one or the
following Tuesday which is the 27th
those are our two possible days for the
Retro reckon tour Christmas celebration
trust me you guys don't want to miss
this one you do not want to miss this
one
um I'll go ahead and tell you guys the
three grand prizes
and if you're wondering what is this
what is this well it's our first time
ever doing this
for the members of house Shrek and tour
here you guys have been such an amazing
Community
um you are such an amazing Community
this has been such an incredible year
that I want to give back in some way
and so we're going to do some giveaways
our community is global it's worldwide
there's a there's a lot more we could do
if everybody was all in one place and
honestly I'm still expecting us to run
into some hiccups even with all of the
planning that I've put into this
um but I will say our three grand prizes
are going to be three copies of the
Hogwarts Legacy deluxe edition I'm gonna
be giving away three
three copies of Hogwarts Legacy Deluxe
this is not sponsored by anybody this is
all coming from me here
this is all me and the community wanting
to give back to you guys so for those of
you uh you know there's some people
upset in the chat tonight some people
who are saying they don't have enough
money for you know for a certain version
or whatever
there's going to be a chance here for
anybody to win one that night platform
of your choice
platform of your choice uh will be
digital it will be the digital copy
and I'll I will whatever platform you
want it on I will purchase the game
we're gonna be doing three of those and
there's gonna be a lot of other stuff
so those are the three big ones but
we're going to be doing some Amazon gift
cards
um if you're a buddy uh buddy oh my gosh
I told you I was fading
my buddy expect to go if you're a member
of his community you know he's got some
pretty fire merch as well
he's gonna be donating a merch item to
give away
I'm gonna be giving away some of my
merch as well and then
oh also
hold on yeah this one's this one's
finalized so I could say also a copy of
God of War Ragnarok
again digital copy that you can redeem
for PS4 or PS5
so those are those are all for sure I
just got to figure out how many gotta
gotta tally up all the money there
um so but the for sure is though three
copies of Hogwarts Legacy Deluxe
platform of your choice
it's sponsored by the super chats
exactly Noob exactly that that is
this giveaway is sponsored by the super
Chatters of retro record tour that's it
so uh three copies of Hogwarts Legacy
Deluxe that is for sure locked in one
copy of God of War Ragnarok on I think
it'll actually work for PS4 or uh PS5
uh James is going to be donating
an item then I'm gonna have some merch
items and then some Amazon gift cards so
um I wanted to have enough things that
I mean I want you guys to have a good
chance of winning but obviously the more
things I do I have to make them less
value like I'll be honest with you guys
I would love to have just done one big
giveaway
for a Hogwarts Place collector's edition
but then only one person wins that you
know and that's not that's not as fun so
I'd rather have like 10 15 however many
we decide on the other stuff winners so
you guys can at least win a little
something Draco with the Super Chat just
a thank you Draco thank you so much
always wonder if I'm saying your name
correctly because I think you but I
think I asked you before and I think you
said Draco
if it's supposed to be Jericho or
anything else let me please clarify and
let me know my apologies but thank you
all for the support 239 likes
let's go my friends
thank you guys for hitting that like
button that helps more people find the
Stream
laughs
yeah if you're a buddy Mike
phew
I don't know what what I'm saying Chris
trying to say my buddy James if you're
familiar with his community and it came
out if you're a buddy
yeah I don't know
love the backdrop hey thanks Logan
appreciate it yeah we got the little
got the you probably can't actually tell
too well from this shot but yeah there's
a lot of Harry Potter ornaments on here
I showed him off in closer detail on my
Twitter and Instagram
you guys can get a closer look at some
of the ornaments
oh my gosh I almost forgot I almost
forgot I almost forgot okay I'm so glad
you mentioned the tree
okay last thing last thing last thing
and then we gotta then I gotta bounce
all right I'm gonna go full cam for this
though
and we gotta I think I'm gonna have to
turn my light as well
oh goodness that's so bright
I love The Vibes more when when it's out
all right so we're gonna
we're gonna do a very quick little
unboxing here a very quick little
unboxing
for so my mom when I told her I was
doing this
she had to get me these little uh I
don't know where she found these
but we have these
Harry Potter mystery ornaments
[Music]
so this will be this will be what we do
for the 200 guys for the 200.
no impre no Impressions tonight
oh that's just that's what Elwood Super
Chat 247
you can impression we'll do we'll do not
one but two in boxings
so okay here's what I want to hear first
though I this the scheme is so weird so
it's like here's how many they have in
here
so
you got a golden snitch
see that little Green Dot beside it
you've got Luna Lovegood
you got Hagrid and Dumbledore with the
yellows so apparently green
let me see green is super rare so the
snitch is super rare for some reason
[Applause]
oh Noob you're blocking everybody noob
Noob your Super Chat
there you go Hermione Voldemort and then
Harry Potter
no Noob you don't have to donate you
don't have to donate for the uh for the
giveaway
all of your guys's donations from the
year are making this giveaway possible
I love I mean you guys are so generous
Nico volunteered he's like to help as
well that's that's not the point I
appreciate appreciate it I definitely do
but the support you guys have shown all
year is why we're even in a position to
be doing it so thank you thank you all
right so for some reason the golden
snitch is super rare
it's super rare uh Luna Hagrid and
Dumbledore are considered rare
and then Voldemort Hermione and Harry
dude are bully Ron
never gets any love but uh Voldemort
Hermione and Harry are considered common
no Ron exactly right
oh that's awesome I love Peter's videos
I love Potter collector all right so
let's go ahead and open one I have two
here to open up all right so let's see
who do you guys think we're gonna get
first
go ahead and call it in the chat
alright so just the packaging on the
outer
Edge there
all right I'm gonna try to like look at
it through the light and see if we can
tell
mystery Hallmark mystery ornaments
all right we got Voldemort and a snitch
Nico says Luna couple saying Luna my
dog's name is Luna so that one would be
fitting Dumbledore no cheating
mud blood
what Zach
come on now
oh my gosh Owen's like no you're not
you're not allowed to color that in here
oh when blocking that one okay I
actually think it might be Luna guys
how in the world do you get this open
is there a button you press or do I just
have to oh goodness
guys
you guys nailed it
we had so many people saying Luna
nailed it oh she's adorable
this my wife's gonna be so happy she
loves Luna my wife has uh some of the
Specter specs one year for Halloween I
went as Harry and she went as Luna
oh they won't stand up though I'm gonna
have to put it on the tree
we'll just lay her down right there for
now
Okay so
next one
all right so Luna was actually in the
category of rare
she was the rare category
alright so let's go ahead and open up
our next one
these again the Hallmark Harry Potter
mystery ornaments
all right come on I don't understand why
the golden snitches the
okay we got hold on I'm gonna put it in
my hand without looking next is Ron
Ron's not even in here
all right hold on I'm just gonna try to
I'm gonna try to guess by
oh I feel like this is uh this has got
to be a Dumbledore Hagrid or no I guess
Hermione I feel like it has long hair
it's definitely not a golden snitch all
right I'm gonna let I'm gonna let you
guys see it first
okay I saw the camera refocus all right
I'm gonna look now yo it's our boy
rubius Hagrid
keeper of keys and games at Hogwarts
[Music]
so wait did we get two that say they
were a wizard
yo Hagrid
we got two that say they are rare
we didn't get any of the commons so
Voldemort Hermione and Harry are the
commons so we got Hagrid and Luna
and a lot of people actually got it
quite good [ __ ] yeah as soon as I was
just kind of feeling I was like okay
this feels like a lot of hair on this
one
Hagrid Kenobi I know Ma I'll be like
where did you get these
where did you get these they're such
cute ornaments though I love them
so we'll have to find a place for them
on the tree which is it's probably good
that I got these two because
obviously we already have a lot of
Harry Potter ornaments on the tree oh
come on Hagrid Hagrid Luna they're
they're camera shy stop being camera shy
you guys it's okay
it's just chat they're friendly they all
love you here Hagrid
Hagrid come on Hagrid
Hagrid
okay there it's like
it's like that's it
Walmart Amazon nice Voldemort is pretty
common yeah Voldemort was on the he was
listed as common
all right that's gonna be it though for
tonight mom thanks for the gifts she's
not watching but we'll think it's always
good to thank your mom guys thank you
thank your mom anyway all right
everybody have a fantastic evening we
will be live hope to see you guys there
for the gameplay showcase tomorrow and
it's gonna be a fun day man gonna be a
fun day so if you missed a stream if
you're wondering our reaction to all the
news of today we started off with the
bad news then we moved into the good
news then we talked about the gameplay
showcase and everything coming up
tomorrow
we also had a new video today on jumping
I know right jumping it's big Dylan
Hogwarts Legacy
it's a big deal
and we helped make it happen guys we
helped make it happen the worst Hammer
Alicia's you know Alicia's
disappointment Alicia asking me like
retro come on can you do anything
guys retro apologize to Alicia I'm like
what do I have to apologize for
I don't have anything to apologize for
but but I will I will try and use our
powers for good oh you guys know what
you know what we should do
I saw some people suggesting on Twitter
that we needed to also Channel our
energies into making
swimming happening
so
I mean let's let's just do it right
right now
by the power of of the Retro rack and
tour chat the community here
what all did I say last time hold on
hold on let me think what all did we say
oh yeah it was it was like the Patronus
that's right we have to summon guys you
have to think you have to think good
positive thoughts
just like the Patronus think that happy
thought and then we're gonna cast it out
into the world
we're gonna make it happen swimming
in Hogwarts Legacy I feel like I feel
like this one's I feel like we're asking
for a little bit more a touch a touch
more than what we
than what we got with jumping maybe
maybe
just keep swimming just keep swimming
indeed
indeed
all right guys thank you all so much for
the love and support hope you all have a
fantastic rest of your evening or rest
of your morning depending on where you
are
thank you all so much for watching and I
will talk to you again soon
very soon like
tomorrow soon
later guys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]